le mouvement que je fais là c'est le
mouvement qui teste des ligaments
croisés antérieurs du goût revient
estime que les spécialistes québécois
ont comblé l'important fossé salarial
qui existait avec leurs collègues du
reste du pays un malaise palpable
c'est pourquoi les hausse de 11,2 pour
cent sur huit ans lui semble importante
même si la moitié de cette somme leur
est dû en vertu d'un temps de penser on
a vu le la situation des infirmières qui
étaient décriées aussi le ratio patients
patients infirmières donc tout ça dans
le contexte on aurait annonce encore une
augmentation substantielle de la
rémunération je pense que ça explique le
malaise actuel qui est partagé par
beaucoup de nicole est ce que les
spécialistes de manière générale est ce
que vous vous attendiez à plus d'argent
a plus d'argent non pas vraiment pour
l'orthopédiste julio fernandes les
sentiments sont partagés chez les
spécialistes
il ya eu vraiment en silence assez assez
révélateur la peau des questions
accréditant la fmsq ne donne pas
d'entrevue pour l'instant mais dans une
lettre dont nous avons obtenu copie la
présidente diane francoeur appel aux
spécialistes qui l'ont accepté d'étaler
les os pour contribuer à assainir les
finances publiques
si nous avons fait une erreur écrit-elle
elle aura été de proposer des thalys sur
10 ans le rattrapage qui nous a été
consentie étude à l'appui
julio fernandez pense que les futures
hausses des spécialistes auraient pu
servir aux autres professionnels ou à
réorganiser les services où sont les
infirmiers clinicienne où sont inclinés
10 fermé ou sont les physiothérapeutes
cliniciens où sont les sages femmes ou
son où sont les os ou six ans on doit
travailler à la réorganisation du
travail plus qu'à la négociation
d'ententes salariale avec la communauté
médicale
la fmsq affirme d'ailleurs que l'entente
dont les détails n'ont pas encore été
divulgués comprend plusieurs mesures
pour améliorer les services aux patients
ici david gentil la radio canada
montréal